[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: All
right, let's get started.
So today, we're going to talk
at some length about what
I mean by this idea of
Marr's computational theory
level of analysis.
It's a way of asking questions
about mind and brain,
and we're going
to talk about that
in the case of color vision.
And that's going
to take a while.
We'll go down and do the demo.
We'll come back and
talk about color vision
and how we think about it at the
level of computational theory
and why that matters
for mind and brain.
And then we're going to
start, in the second half,
a whole session, which is
going to roll into next class,
on the methods we can use
in cognitive neuroscience
to understand the human brain,
and we'll illustrate those
with a case of face perception.
And we'll talk about
computational theory,
light very briefly,
a face perception,
what you can learn from
behavioral studies,
and what you can learn
from functional MRI.
And then we'll go on and
do other methods next time.
Everybody with the program?
All right.
So to back up a little,
the biggest theme addressed
in this course, the
big question we're
trying to understand
in this field is,
how does the brain
give rise to the mind?
That's really what
we're in it for.
That's why there's lots
of cognitive science.
We're trying to understand
how the mind emerges
from this physical object.
And so for the
last few lectures,
you've been learning some
stuff about the physical basis
of the brain, what it
actually looks like.
Some of you guys
got to touch it.
I hope you thought that was
half as awesome as I did.
And we got a sense of the
basic physicality of the brain
and some of its major parts.
But now the agenda
is, how are we
going to explain how this
physical object gives rise
to something like the mind?
And the first
problem you encounter
is, what is the mind anyway?
I drew it as a weird,
big, amorphous cloud
because it's just not obvious
how you think about minds,
right?
It feels like one
of those things
like, we could even have
a science of the mind.
What is mind?
All kind of nervous
making, right?
And so our field of
cognitive science,
over the last few
decades, has come up
with this framework for how
we can think about minds,
and this isn't even a theory.
It's more meta than that.
It's a framework for thinking
about what a mind is,
and the framework is
the idea that the mind
is a set of computations
that extract representations.
OK, now that's pretty abstract.
You can think of
a representation
in your mind as
anything from a percept,
like I see motion right
now, or I see color.
And as you learned before,
you might see motion
even if there isn't actually
motion in the stimulus.
But that representation
of motion in your head,
that percept, that's a kind
of mental representation.
Or if you're thinking, why is
Nancy going through this really
basic stuff?
She's insulting
our intelligence.
If something like that is
going on in the background
as I'm lecturing,
that's a thought.
That's a mental
representation of a sort.
Or if you're thinking, oh
my god, it's after 11:00,
and I'm not going to
get to eat until 12:30.
I'm going to starve.
Whatever thoughts are
going through your head,
those are mental
representations, too, right?
And so the question is, how
do we think about those?
And so this idea that mental
processes are computations
and mental contents
are representations
implies that ideally, in
the long run, if we really
understood minds, we'd
be able to write the code
to do everything
that minds do, right?
And that code would work, in
some sense, in the same way.
Now, that's a tall order.
Mostly, we can't do that
yet, like not even close,
a few little cases
in perception,
kind of sort of maybe, but
mostly, we can't do that yet.
But that's the goal.
That's the aspiration.
And so the question
is, how do we even
get off the ground
trying to launch
this enterprise
of coming up with
an actual precise computational
theory of what minds do?
And the first step to that is by
thinking about what is computed
and why, and so that is the
crux of David Marr's big idea,
the brief reading assignment
that I gave you guys from Marr.
And he's talking
about, how do we
think about minds and brains?
Step number one, what
is computed and why?
So we're going to focus
on that for a bit here.
And let's take
vision, for example.
You start with a
world out there that
sends light into your eyes.
That's my icon of a retina,
that blue thing in the back,
the back of your eyes--
sends an image onto your eye,
and then some magic happens.
And then you know what
you're looking at, OK?
So that's what we're
trying to understand.
What goes on in there?
In a sense, what
is the code that
goes on in here that
takes this as an input
and delivers that
as an output, OK?
More specifically,
we can ask, as we
did in the last
couple of lectures--
let's take the case
of visual motion.
So suppose you're seeing
a display like this,
like something in front of you.
Somebody jumps on
a beach like that,
and there's visual
motion information.
What are the kinds of things--
so that's your input.
What are the kinds of outputs
you might get from that?
Well, to understand that, we
need to know what is computed
and why.
So what is computed?
Well, lots of things.
You might see the
presence of motion.
presence of a person.
Actually, you can
detect people just
from their pattern of motion.
We should have done
this at the demo.
Write me a note to think
about that next time.
If we stuck a little tiny
LEDs on each of my joints
and we're in a totally black
room and I jumped around
and all you could see
was those dots moving,
you would see that
it was a person.
It would be trivially obvious.
So motion can give you
lots of information
aside from "something's
moving" and "what direction
is it moving?"
You can see someone's jumping.
That also comes from the
information about motion.
You can infer something
about the health
of this person or
even their mood,
so there's a huge range
of kinds of information
we glean from even a pretty
simple stimulus attribute
like motion.
And so if we're
going to understand
how do we perceive
motion, we first
need to get organized
about, what's the input,
and which of those outputs
are we talking about?
And probably, the code that
goes on in between in your head
or in a computer program,
if you ever figured out
how to do that, will
be quite different
for each of those
things, but that's
the way you need to be
thinking about minds.
OK, what are the inputs?
What are the outputs?
And then as soon as you
pose that challenge--
OK, let's say it's
just moving dots,
and you're trying to
tell if that's a person.
Think about, what is
the code you'd write?
Just these moving dots.
How the hell are you
going to go from that
to detecting if those dots are
on the joints of a person who's
moving around versus
on something else?
That's how you think, what are
the computational challenges
involved, OK?
And I'm not going to ever ask
you guys to write that code.
We're just going to consider
it as a thought enterprise
to kind of see what the problem
is that the brain is facing,
that it's solving.
OK, and so Marr's big idea
is this whole business
of thinking about what
is computed and why,
what the inputs and
outputs are, and what
the computational challenges
are getting from those inputs
to those outputs,
that all of that
is a prerequisite for thinking
about minds or brains, OK?
So we can't understand what
brains are doing until we first
think about this.
That's why I'm carrying on
about this at some length.
And Marr writes so
beautifully that I'm just
going to read some of
my favorite paragraphs
because paraphrasing
beautiful prose is a sin.
So Marr says, "Trying
to understand perception
by studying only
neurons is like trying
to understand bird flight
by studying only feathers.
It just can't be done.
To understand bird
flight, you need
to understand aerodynamics.
Only then can one make sense
of the structure of feathers
and the shape of wings.
Similarly, you can't
reach an understanding
of why neurons in
the visual system
behave the way they do just
by studying their anatomy
and physiology," OK?
You have to understand the
problem that's being solved,
OK?
Further, he says, "The
nature of the computations
that underlie
perception depends more
on the computational
problems that
have to be solved than on the
particular hardware in which
their solutions
are implemented."
So he's basically
saying we could
have a theory of any
aspect of perception
that would be essentially
the same theory whether you
write it in code and
put it in a computer
or whether it's being
implemented in a brain.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was Marr an engineer?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Marr was many things.
He was a visionary,
a visionary who
studied vision, a
truly brilliant guy
with a very strong
engineering background.
And this is now
pervading the whole field
of cognitive science, that
people take an engineering
approach to understanding
minds and brains,
to try to really
understand how they work.
OK, so to better
understand this,
we're going to now consider
the case of color vision.
And so in this case,
we start with color
in the world that sends images
onto the back of your retina,
so magic happens.
And we get a bunch
of information out.
So the question we're
going to consider
is, what do we
use color for, OK?
And we're going to
use the same strategy
we used in the Edgerton Center.
We're trying to understand
some of the things
that we use color for by
experiencing perception
without color, OK?
What are the outputs?
OK, so to do that, we're
going to head over right now
to the imaging center,
and we're going
to have a cool demo
by Rosa Lafer-Sousa.
So if it's going to be faster
to leave your stuff here--
I don't know.
Maybe we should-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
we'll lock the room, OK?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How long are
we going to be there?
NANCY KANWISHER: 10 minutes,
something like that,
and I need everyone to boogie
because there's a lot of stuff
I want to get through today.
So let's go.
All right, so what do we use
color for when we have it?
It's not a trick question.
It's supposed to be
really obvious now.
Yeah, what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Chardon.
NANCY KANWISHER: Chardon, hi.
AUDIENCE: Like choosing
which food to eat.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, yeah.
Choosing which.
What else related to
that but different?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Check-in procedure.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, yeah, like what?
What did you notice that
you could identify better?
AUDIENCE: Different
types of things.
NANCY KANWISHER: Mm-hmm,
but besides identifying
and choosing, what else?
AUDIENCE: More generally,
bringing things
into our awareness with
the reds in particular
with the strawberries.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, do
you find them easier to find?
AUDIENCE: No, much harder.
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
yeah, right, harder
without the light, right.
Exactly.
What else.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like driving.
You need to have color to
know the traffic lights.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Totally, totally.
That's a modern invention
but a really important one.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Are we general?
Are we very general or like--
NANCY KANWISHER: Whatever.
What do we use color for?
AUDIENCE: I mean, we
used to figure out
what to eat because
one of the strawberries
wasn't actually a strawberry.
So yeah, I used
color to [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER:
Uh-huh, and the bananas.
Did anybody notice?
Sometimes, it's hard to tell.
Yeah, boy in the back?
AUDIENCE: For
assessing health risks.
NANCY KANWISHER: Say more.
AUDIENCE: If someone's face
doesn't have color in it,
you tend to assume
that they're sickly.
NANCY KANWISHER: Totally.
Did you feel like people's
faces looked a little sickly?
Absolutely, absolutely.
OK, so this is just to show
you that a lot of computation
theory starts with common
sense of just reasoning, what
do we use this stuff for?
It helps to not have it to
reveal what we use it for,
but you guys have just
reinvented the key insights
in early field of color vision.
OK, so standard story
is to find fruit.
If you ask yourself how
many berries are here,
take a moment.
Get a mental tally.
How many berries?
OK, ready?
Now how many berries, OK?
You see more.
And in fact, there's a long
literature showing that
primates who have
three cone colors--
we're not going to go through
all the physiological basis
of cones and stuff like that,
but they have a richer color
vision because the number
of different color receptors
in their retina--
they're better at
finding berries.
And in fact, a paper came
out a couple of years
ago where they studied wild
macaques on an island off
of Puerto Rico
called Cayo Santiago,
and the macaques there have a
natural variation genetically
where some of them have two
color photoreceptors instead
of three, OK?
And in fact, they
followed them around,
and the monkeys that have
three photoreceptor types
are better at finding fruit than
the ones that have only two,
OK?
So that story that's just
been a story for a long time
turns out it's true.
And also, as you
guys have already
said, to not just find things
but identify properties--
you can probably
tell whether you'd
want to eat those
bananas on the bottom.
Maybe not, but it's hard to tell
on the top which ones you like.
And yet that's all
you need to know, OK?
So these are just a few of
the ways that we use color
and why it's important.
But there is a very big problem
now that we try to figure out,
OK, what is the code that goes
between the wavelength of light
hitting your retina and
trying to figure out,
what color is that thing?
So here's the problem.
We want to determine a
property of the object,
of its surface properties,
its color, right?
That's a material
property of that thing.
But all we have--
so here's a thing.
We'll call that reflectance.
It's a property of wavelength,
but you can think of it as,
for now, just a single number.
It's a property of that
surface, but all we
have is the light coming
from that object to our eyes.
That's called luminance.
I'm not going to test you
on these particular words,
but you should get the idea, OK?
So that's what we have.
That's our input.
But here's the problem.
The light that's
coming off the object
is a function not
just of the object
but of the nature of the light
that's shining on the object.
That's called the illuminant.
So the problem is we
have this equation.
This light coming from
the object to our eyes
is the product of the properties
of the surface and the incident
light, OK?
And our problem is, we have
to solve for L. I'm sorry.
We have to solve for R,
the property of the object.
Given L, what is R?
That's a problem, OK?
That's kind of like if
I said, A times B is 48.
Please solve for A and B, OK?
That's known in the field as
an ill-posed or underdetermined
problem.
We don't have enough information
to uniquely solve this, OK?
That's a very, very deep
problem in perception
and a lot of cognition.
We are often, in fact, most
of the time in this boat, OK?
So the implications
are, when we want
to infer reflectance of the
property of the object from L,
we must bring in other
information, right?
We must have some
way to make guesses
about I, about the light
shining on that object, OK?
So the big point is
many, many inferences
in perception and cognition are
ill posed in exactly this way,
all right?
And so here are two other
examples of ill-posed problems
in perception.
In shape perception, you
have a similar situation.
You have stuff in
the world that's
making an image on the
back of your eyes, OK?
That's optics.
What we're trying
to do as perceivers
is reason backwards
from that image.
What object in the world
caused that image on my retina?
That's sometimes
called inverse optics
because you're trying to
reason the opposite way.
That's basically what
we're doing in vision.
So here's a problem.
It's a crappy diagram,
but if you can see here,
there's three very different
surface shapes here
that are all casting the
same image, for example,
on a retina.
You could do this with cardboard
and cast it with a shadow.
So everybody get
what this shows here?
What that means is if
you start with this
and you have to reason backwards
to the shape that caused it,
that's an ill posed
problem, big time.
It could be any of those things.
This information
doesn't constrain it.
Does everybody see that problem?
OK, so that's another
ill-posed problem.
Here's a totally different
example of an ill-posed problem
that's big in cognition.
When you learn the meaning
of a word, especially
as an infant trying to learn
language, the classic example
the philosophers like--
God knows why.
Philosophers like weird
stuff, but never mind.
Somebody points to that and
says "gavagai," and your job
is to figure out, what
does "gavagai" mean, OK?
So "gavagai" could mean all
kinds of different things.
It could just mean
rabbit if you already
have a concept of a rabbit.
It could mean fur.
It could mean ears.
It could mean motion if the
rabbit is jumping around,
or in the example of
the philosophers love,
it could mean
undetached rabbit parts.
Weird, but anyway, philosophers
like that kind of thing.
Anyway, the point
is, it's ill posed.
We don't know from this
what is the correct meaning
of the word.
Does everybody see how
this underdetermines
the correct meaning of the word?
We don't have enough
information to solve it, OK?
So yeah-- blah, blah.
So there's a whole literature
on the extra assumptions
that infants bring to bear
to constrain that problem,
so they can make
a damn good guess
about what the actual
meaning of the word is, OK?
It's a whole big literature,
quite fascinating.
OK, but for now, I just
want you to understand
what an ill-posed
problem is and why
it's central to understanding
perception and cognition.
OK, so back to
the case of color.
As I said, the big point is that
lots of inferences, including
determining the reflectance
of an object, are ill posed,
and so we have to bring in
assumptions and knowledge
from other places, from our
knowledge of the statistics
and the physics of the
world, our knowledge
of particular objects.
All kinds of other things
must be brought to bear, OK?
So all of that, again, is
considering the problem
of color vision at the level
of Marr's computational theory.
Notice we haven't made
any measurements yet.
We've just thought
about light and optics
and what the problem is
and what we use it for, OK?
All this stuff.
What is extracted and why?
R, the reflectance of an object,
useful for characterizing
objects and finding them.
What cues are available?
Only L, and that's a problem
because it's ill posed.
OK, next question-- so
obviously, we get around,
and we can figure out
what colors are which.
What are the other
sources of information
that we might use in principle
and that humans do use
in practice, OK?
And so all of that
kind of stuff has
been done without
making any measurements.
We're just thinking about
the problem itself, OK?
All right, so next, Marr's other
levels of analysis, algorithm
and representation in hardware,
are more standard ones
you will have
encountered, which is
why I'm making a big deal
of computational theory.
It's really his major
novel contribution,
but it's better understood
by contrast with these.
So at the level of algorithm
and representation,
this is like, what is the
code that you would write
to solve that problem, right?
And so we could ask, how does
the system do what it does?
Can we write the code
to do it, and what
assumptions and computations
and representations
would be entailed?
So how would we find
out how humans do this?
Well, one of the ways is a
slightly more organized version
of what you guys just did, and
that's called psychophysics.
Psychophysics just means
showing people stuff
and asking them what they
see or playing them sounds
and asking them what they hear.
And you can do it in very
sophisticated, formalized ways,
or you can do it
like we just did.
Talk to us about what
the world looks like, OK?
Usually, psychophysics means
a slightly more organized
version.
OK, so here's an example.
In fact, it's a cool
demo, also from Rosa.
And so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to show you a bunch
of pictures of cars,
and your task is going to be to
shout out loud as fast as you
can the color of the car, OK?
They're going to
appear on the screen.
Everyone ready?
As fast as you can,
shout it out loud.
Here we go.
What color?
AUDIENCE: Red.
AUDIENCE: Green.
AUDIENCE: It's green.
NANCY KANWISHER: Interesting.
OK, here's another one.
AUDIENCE: Blue.
AUDIENCE: Yellow.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Uh-huh, interesting.
Ready?
Here we go.
Here's another one.
AUDIENCE: Green.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
here's another one.
AUDIENCE: Blue.
NANCY KANWISHER: Ah,
you guys cottoned
on to that pretty fast.
OK, so good job.
Nice consensus,
although I noticed
a little bit of
transition there,
which is very interesting.
But here's the thing.
All of those cars are
the exact same color.
The body of the car is the
exact same in all of them,
and if you don't believe it,
I'm going to include everything
except for a patch, OK?
Here we go.
Boom, they're all gray.
I know.
It's awesome.
It's Rosa that's
awesome, not me.
I just had to bum this
because it's so awesome.
OK, so Rosa spent months
designing these stimuli to test
particular ideas about
vision, but the basic demo
is simple and straightforward.
You can get the point here, OK?
So what's going on here?
What's going on here is that
you guys, the algorithm running
in your head that's
trying to figure out
what is the color
of that car, is
trying to solve the
ill-posed problem,
and it's using other information
than just the luminance
of light coming from the object.
It's using information from
the rest of the object.
It's making inferences about
L, the luminance, the light
hitting the object, OK?
And in particular, when you
look at that picture up there,
what is the color of
light shining on that car?
AUDIENCE: Green.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
right, officially
known as teal in the
field, but some of you
shouted out "green"
first because that's
what you saw first, is
the color of light, OK?
What's the color of
light hitting that car?
Yeah, purple, magenta.
Here?
AUDIENCE: Blue.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, and over there?
AUDIENCE: Yellow.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, yellow-orange.
Yeah, OK, so basically
what your visual system did
is look quickly, figure out the
color of the incident light, L,
and use that to solve the
otherwise ill-posed problem
of solving for R,
the color of the car.
And in this case,
this demo shows
that if you just change the
color of the illuminant light
and hold constant the
actual wavelengths coming
from that patch, you can
radically change the perceived
color of the car.
Everyone got that?
OK.
AUDIENCE: So wait, wait, wait--
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you ran
this through a computer,
asked it to get the
intensity of the pixel
on the hood of the car there, it
would not correspond to yellow,
it would correspond to green?
NANCY KANWISHER: Well,
it depends what you're
asking the computer exactly.
If you hold up a
spectrophotometer that's
just going to measure
the wavelength of light,
they're all gray.
Right there on
top of those cars,
they're all the exact
same neutral gray.
That's just the raw physical
light coming from that patch,
OK?
But if you coded up the
computer to do something smart
and you coded it up to take
other cues from the image,
try to figure out what L is,
and therefore solve for R,
you might be able to get
it to do the right thing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean just
like you looked at the pixels,
like in the matrix, I
mean, the color on the car,
would it be what yellow is,
or would it be more grays?
NANCY KANWISHER: Gray.
They're all gray.
So that's what I
was trying to show
you here is that, in fact,
they are actually gray, right?
The cars are underneath
there, and you can see
they're all exactly the same.
And they're gray, and
there's no color in it, OK?
Everyone got that?
All right, OK, so all
of that is a little baby
example of
psychophysics, what we
do at the level of trying
to understand the algorithms
and representations extracted by
the mind to try to figure out,
what are the strategies that
we use to solve problems
about the visual world?
OK, and so behavior or
psychophysics or seeing,
as you just did, can
reveal those assumptions
and reveal some of
the tricks that we're
using in the human
visual system to solve
those ill-posed problems, OK?
So in this case,
it was assumptions
about the illuminant
that enabled
us to infer the reflectance
from the luminance.
OK, the third level
Marr talks about
is the level of
hardware implementation.
In the case of brains,
that's neurons and brains,
and so we won't cover
this in any detail here.
But there's lots and
lots of work on the brain
basis of color vision.
We'll mention it
briefly next time.
So this is some of
Rosa's work showing
those little blue patches on
the side of the monkey brain
that are involved
in color vision,
and some work that
Rosa did in my lab
showing the bottom
surface of the human brain
with a very similar organization
with those little blue patches
in there that are particularly
sensitive to color.
So you can study brain
regions that do that.
If it's a monkey, you can
stick electrodes in there
and record from
individual neurons
and see what they code
for, and you can really
tackle at multiple levels the
hardware neural basis of color
vision in brains as well.
OK, so the big
general point is we
need lots of levels of analysis
to understand a problem
like color vision, OK?
And so accordingly, we
need lots of methods
to understand those
things, all right?
So what I want to do
next is now launch
into this whole thing
about the different methods
that we can use in the field,
and this part of the lecture
will go on to next time.
But let's get going.
Everybody good with this so far?
All right, so we're going to
use the case of face perception
to think about the
different kinds of questions
and different levels of
analysis in face perception.
So let me start by saying,
why face perception?
Not just that I've worked
on it for 20 years,
although I'll admit
that's relevant.
There's lots of
other good reasons
beyond that, why we should
care about face perception.
So I don't have a demo that
enables me to kind of put you
in a situation where you can
see everything but faces.
That would be cool
and informative
if we could do that,
but failing that,
I can tell you about somebody
who's in that situation.
And this is a guy
named Jacob Hodes.
So this is a picture
of him recently.
I met him around a
decade ago when he
was a freshman at Swarthmore.
And he sent me an
email, and he said,
I've just learned about face
perception and the phenomenon
of prosopagnosia, the
fact that some people
have a specific deficit
in face recognition.
And it explains everything in
my life, and I want to meet you.
And I said-- because he knew
I worked on face perception.
I said, that's awesome.
I would love to meet you,
but I got to tell you,
I'm not going to
be able to help.
So if you're interested
in chatting, please,
please come by, but
I don't want you
to feel like I'm going to be
able to do anything useful.
He said, no, I don't care.
I want to understand
the science.
So he comes by, and by
the way, one of the things
that people have
wondered for a while is,
are people who have
particular problems with face
recognition-- are they
just socially weird?
Are they just bizarre, maybe
a little bit on the spectrum?
They don't pay
attention to faces,
and so they don't get them
very well and so forth.
Or can they be totally
normal in every other respect
except for just face perception?
And so I was very interested.
I'd only emailed with this
guy, and when he showed up
in my office, within
about 15 seconds,
it's like, this is like the
nicest, normalest kid you
could ever meet.
Such a nice guy, so normal,
socially adept, smart,
thoughtful-- lovely,
lovely person.
So I chatted with
him for a long time,
and he told me he
was then halfway
through-- he grew up
in Lynn, Massachusetts,
and he went off to
Swarthmore his freshman year.
And he had been having a
really rough time of it
because in his hometown, he
was with the same group of kids
all the way from first
grade through high school.
And so in fact, he just
can't recognize faces at all,
never could.
When he was a little kid
his mom used to drive him
to the practice field, and they
would sit there and come up
with cues about, this is
how you tell that's Johnny.
He's got this weird
thing about his hair,
and this is how you
tell that's Bobby.
And they would
practice and practice.
And so he developed
these clues to be
able to figure out who was
who in his small little cohort
of kids that he knew all
the way through high school.
Then he goes off to college,
and it's all these new people.
And he's screwed.
And he said to me
that he was just
devastated because he
would go to a party,
and he would meet
someone and think, wow,
this is a really nice person.
I would really like to
be this person's friend,
but he would realize
he would have no way
to find that person again.
And he's like, it's
kind of oversharing
to say when you've met somebody
for 10 minutes, by the way,
I'm not going be
able to find you.
You have to find me.
It's like, you just don't want
to have to go there yet, right?
So there's all kinds of things
that would make it a real drag
to not be able to
recognize other faces,
and now having said all of that,
I'll say that a surprisingly
large of the population is in
Jacob's situation, about 2%
of the population.
It would be
unsurprising if there
were one or two of you
in here, and if there is,
you can tell me later.
I'd love to scan you.
But about 2% of the
population routinely
fails to recognize
family members, people
they know really well, right?
And interestingly, this is
completely uncorrelated with IQ
or with any other perceptual
ability or ability
to read or recognize
scenes or anything else.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this
the kind of thing
where you either have
it or don't have it?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Oh, good question.
No, it's a gradation.
So the 2% at the bottom are not
this 2% who are really screwed,
and everyone else is up here.
It's a hugely wide
distribution, and the point
is that the bottom end
of that distribution
is really, really bad.
They just can't do it at all.
Similarly, the top end of that
distribution is weirdly good.
They are so good
at face recognition
that they have to hide it
socially because otherwise
people feel creeped out.
For example, as one
of those people--
they're called
super recognizers.
A bunch of them have been
hired by investigation services
in London recently
as part of their kind
of crime-solving unit.
Those people are so
good that one of them
said to me-- we scanned
a few of these people.
One of them said, if I--
she recounted this
event where she's
standing in line waiting
for movie tickets,
and she realizes that the
person in front of her in line
was sitting at the next
table over at a cafe four
years before.
She says, if I share this
information with that person,
they'll be creeped
out, so I've just
learned to keep it to myself.
But I know that was
the same person, right?
So there's a huge spread.
You had a question a while back.
AUDIENCE: It's not a problem
with recognizing facial images,
is it?
So for example, Jacob,
looking at a person,
could he describe them?
NANCY KANWISHER: Absolutely.
He knows that it's a face.
He can tell if they're
male or female.
He can tell if
they're happy or sad.
It looks like a face to him.
It just doesn't look
different than anyone else.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any difference--
OK, for example, my father-- he
can tell faces in person just
fine, but when he watches videos
of people, he just cannot.
He cannot recognize
faces at all,
so is there any difference?
NANCY KANWISHER: There
are lots of cues.
I mean, that's a very
interesting exercise
to think about.
What are the cues that
you have in person, right?
You have all kinds
of other things.
So first of all, there's lots
of constraining information.
The person you're
looking at-- there
are all kinds of things you
know about where you are
and who that might
be that help, right?
So yeah, there's
many different cues
to face recognition that
might be engaged here.
So my point is just that
face recognition matters.
You can get by if you
can't do it, but it sucks.
It's really hard, OK?
OK, so yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any idea what people
at [INAUDIBLE] university?
Are there any sort
of models that
suggest that when there are--
like, when they see
faces, do they just
see a sort of
conglomerate of shapes?
NANCY KANWISHER: No, they see
the structure of the face.
They see a proper face.
If the eye was in the wrong
place, they would know.
They absolutely know the
structure of the face.
They all look kind of the same.
By the way, we won't
have time to talk
about this in any
detail, but there's
a well-known fact that
probably many of you guys
have experienced, which is
called the other-race effect.
And that is the fact that
they all look the same.
Whoever they are, if you
have less experience looking
at that group of
people, you're less well
able to tell them apart, OK?
I have this problem
teaching all the time.
I grew up in a rural
lily-white community.
My face recognition is
not so good to begin with,
and it's really not good
for non-Caucasian faces.
It's embarrassing as hell.
It feels disrespectful.
I hate it.
I fault myself,
but actually, it's
just a fact of the
perceptual system.
Your perceptual system is tuned
to the statistics of its input,
and it's not so
plastic later in life.
And so a way to simulate
a version that some of you
may have experienced is
whatever race of faces
you have less
experience with, if you
find those people
hard to distinguish,
it's not that you
can't tell it's a face.
It's not that you wouldn't be
able to tell if the nose was
in the wrong place.
It's just hard to tell
one person from another,
so it's a lot like that.
I really need to get going,
so I'll take one more question
and go.
AUDIENCE: Wait, could you
kind of use an analogy?
It's like being able
to tell people apart
by their hands or something
to the point that you just--
you can't really tell
people apart by their hands,
usually, so is that kind of
how people with face blindness
feel?
It's just looking
at [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: That's
all you had, yeah.
Yeah, probably, probably.
Yeah, and there is, by the
way, an interesting literature.
You show people photographs
of their own hand
and a bunch of other hands.
People can't pick out
their own hand from--
so yeah, you're right.
We're not so good at that.
OK, I'm going to go ahead.
If you guys are
interested, I could
post-- there's a whole
fascinating literature here,
but actually, I got
dinged last year
for talking about
face recognition too
much and prosopagnosia.
We all heard about it in 900.
So I took most of that out,
and now you guys are asking me.
So I don't know what
the right thing is.
But I'm going to go on, and I
will put some optional readings
online, especially if
you send me an email
and tell me to do that.
OK, so point is,
faces matter a lot.
They matter for the
quality of life.
They're important
because they convey
a huge amount of information,
not just the identity
of the person but also
their age, sex, mood, race,
direction of attention.
So if I'm lecturing
like this right now
and I start doing that, you
guys are going to wonder,
what the hell's
going on over there?
Yeah, I saw a few heads turn.
I'm just doing a little
demo here, right?
We're very attuned to where
other people are looking, OK?
So this is just one of
many different social cues
we get from faces.
There's just an incredibly rich
bunch of information in a face.
We read in aspects of
people's personality
from the shape of their
face even though it's
been shown with some
interesting recent studies
there's absolutely
nothing you can
infer about a
person's personality
from the shape of their face.
We all do it, and we do
it in systematic ways.
Another reason this is
important-- and faces
are some of the
most common stimuli
that we see in daily life,
starting from infancy where,
I think, about 40%
of waking time,
there's a face right in
front of an infant's eyes.
And probably, these abilities
to extract all this information
have been important throughout
our primate ancestry.
So that's just to say, there's
a big space of face perception,
and now we're going to
focus in on just face
recognition, telling who
that person is, all right?
So what questions do we want to
answer about face recognition?
Well, a whole bunch of them, and
what methods do we want to use?
So let's start with
some basic questions
about face recognition.
Well, first, as usual,
we want to know,
what is the structure of the
problem in face recognition?
What are the inputs?
What are the outputs?
Why is it hard, right?
Just as we've been doing
for motion and color--
that's Marr's
computational theory level.
We want to know, how does
face recognition actually
work in humans?
What computations go on?
What representations
are extracted?
And is that answer different?
Are we running different
code in our heads
when we recognize faces from
when we recognize toasters
and apples and dogs, OK?
Another facet of that-- do we
have a totally different system
for face recognition
from the recognition
of all those other things?
If so, then we might
want different theories
of how face recognition works
from our theories of how
object recognition works.
How quickly do we detect
and recognize faces?
That will help constrain
what kinds of computations
might be going on.
And of course, how
was face recognition
actually implemented
in neurons in brains?
So this is just some of the
big, wide-open questions
we want to answer.
So let's consider, what are
our tools for considering
these things?
And you guys should
all know what
tools are available for
thinking at the level of Marr's
computational theory--
basically just thinking, right?
You can collect
some images, too,
but basically to understand
this, we just think.
So for example,
as I keep saying,
at the level of Marr's
computational theory,
we want to know, what is
the problem to be solved?
What is the input?
What is the output?
How might you go from that
input to that output, OK?
So for example,
here's a stimulus
that might hit a retina,
and then some magic happens.
And then you just
say, Julia, OK?
So we want to know, what's
going on in that magic, OK?
And if a different image hits
your retina, you go, oh, Brad.
That is, I wouldn't.
I live in a cave.
I barely get out
of the lab, but I
understand that these are
people most people recognize.
That's why I use them.
That's the question.
What goes on here in the middle?
And your first thought
is, well, duh, easy.
We could just make a
template, a kind of store
the pixels that match that image
and take the incoming image
and see if it exactly matches.
And that's going to
work great, right?
No.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: Different
angles [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Louder.
AUDIENCE: Angles [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
That's not going to work at all.
And the problem is that we don't
just have one picture of Julia
that we can match.
There are loads of loads
of totally different kinds
of pictures of
Julia, all of which
we look at and immediately
go, Julia, no problem, OK?
And so that means, what is it
that we're doing in our heads?
If we're storing templates, we
have to store a lot of them,
OK?
So all those differences
in the images--
so we could memorize
lots of templates.
Well, that has long been
taken as like the reductio ad
absurdum.
That's the ridiculous
hypothesis.
How could that be?
How could there be room in
here to store lots of templates
of each person, and
furthermore, how would that
work for people we don't know?
The other idea, which
is very vague right now,
is that, well, maybe
we extract something
that's common across all
of those, maybe something
like the distance
between the eyes,
something about the
shape of the mouth,
other kinds of
properties that might
be invariant across
those images, that is,
that you could pull out
that information from any
of those images, OK?
It's sounding very vague
because it is vague.
Nobody knows what
those would be,
but the idea is, maybe
there's some image invariant
properties of a face you can
get from here that you can then
store and use to
recognize faces, OK?
So now to think about this,
we can step back and say, OK,
how is this done in machines?
So machine face recognition
didn't work well at all
until very recently, OK?
And then all of a sudden,
a couple of years ago--
here's another paper
from the different one
that I showed you before.
This one is VGGFace, one of
the major deep net systems
for face recognition.
It's widely used.
There was another
one the year before.
All of this since
2014, 2015-- hugely
cited, widely influential.
They're on all your smartphones.
Boom, it all just happened
like nearly overnight
with the availability of lots
of images to train deep nets.
So now these things
are extremely
effective and accurate,
and so in some sense,
those networks are
possible models
of what we're doing in our
heads when we recognize faces.
It doesn't mean we do
it in the same way,
but it's a possibility.
It's a hypothesis
we could test, OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is the current
state of the literature
surrounding getting other
information from people's faces
like moods or what they're--
NANCY KANWISHER: Lots, lots.
There's conferences and
machine vision competitions
on extracting personality
properties, mood properties,
every possible thing
you could imagine.
This is a huge-- a lot of
people care about this.
It's a huge field
in computer vision,
and it's also a huge field
in cognitive science,
asking what humans
pull from faces.
AUDIENCE: How much
success that you've seen?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh god, others
would know that better than me.
I bet it's pretty damn
good, a lot of it.
Yeah, yeah, I mean,
these things are suddenly
extremely effective.
Yeah, OK, and there will be, by
the way, later in the course--
my postdoc, Katharina Dobs,
who knows that literature much
better than I do, will
talk about deep nets
and their application in
human cognitive neuroscience.
And she knows a lot about
the various networks
that process face information.
OK, so this is progress.
Now we have some kind
of computational model.
Trouble is, nobody really has an
intuitive understanding of what
VGGFace is actually doing.
You know how to train one up.
There it is, but we don't really
understand what it's doing.
And further, we have no
idea if what it's doing
is anything like what
humans are doing, OK?
So it's progress that
we have a model now
that we didn't have
like five years ago,
but we still have all
these questions open.
OK, so on this first question,
what do we want to know?
What we discover at
the level of Marr
computational theory is a,
if not the, central challenge
in face recognition is the huge
variation across images, which
you know just by thinking about
it or trying to write the code.
OK, so ooh, I'm
just barely able.
I'm going to race
along, and Anya's
going to tell me in
five minutes to switch.
OK, so I want to talk
just a little bit
about behavioral data.
I'll run out of
time, and we'll roll
this in less time,
because I want
to include functional MRI
because you guys need it
for the assignment.
OK, so how are we going
to figure out what
humans represent about faces?
OK, so here we are.
We consider this
possibility that one way
to solve this problem is by
essentially memorizing lots
of templates for each person.
Another possibility is this
kind of vague, inchoate idea
that maybe there's some abstract
representation that'll be
the same across all of those.
How are we going to figure
out which humans do?
Well, if we're really
memorizing lots of templates
for each person and that's
how we recognize them
in all their different guises,
that wouldn't work for people
we didn't know.
That is, you wouldn't be able to
take two different photographs
of the same person and know if
it's the same person or not,
right?
Because you could only
do this by memorizing.
Does everybody get that idea?
Whereas whatever
this other idea is,
it should work somewhat
for novel individuals
you don't already know.
Here are two photographs.
Same person or different person?
So now let's ask,
can humans do this?
Do we store lots of
templates for individuals,
or can we do something
more abstract?
Well, if we simply
deal with this problem
by storing lots of templates
for each individual,
maybe not literally pixel
templates but some kind
of snapshot, then
the key test is,
we shouldn't be able to do
this matching task if we
don't know that person.
Everybody get the logic here?
OK, so let's try it.
So this paper a few years ago--
Jenkins et al.
Asked that question.
So here's what they did.
They collected a whole
bunch of photographs
of Dutch politicians
with multiple images
of each politician, OK?
Then they gave them to people
on cards, and they said,
there are multiple
images of each person.
And I'm not going to tell you
how many different politicians
are in this deck.
Just sort them in piles,
so there's a different pile
for each person, OK?
I'm going to show you a
low-tech version of this.
whole bunch of pictures,
all in one array,
and you guys are
going to try to figure out
how many people are there, OK?
Everybody ready?
I'm just going to leave
it up for a few seconds.
There's going to be
lots of pictures.
Your task is how many different
individuals are depicted here.
Here we go.
OK, write down your best guess.
Just kind of look around.
OK, everybody got a guess?
OK, write down your guess.
OK, how many people
think there were over 10
different individuals there?
One.
OK, how many people
think over five?
Yeah, probably half of you.
How many people
think over three?
Most of you.
There are two.
What does that mean?
That means you can't do it.
That means you can't
match different images
of the same person if you
don't know that person.
Pretty surprising, isn't it?
We think we're so awesome
at face recognition
because most of the
time, what we're doing
is recognizing people
we know, people
we've seen in all different
viewpoints and hair
arrangements and stuff.
If you don't have
lots of opportunity
to store all those things
and it's a novel face,
we're really bad at that, OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But there's
a constraint of time?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, yeah, I was
trying to make the demo work.
But OK, so the way
they do this task,
people have unlimited
time, and they're just
kind of sorting them.
The mean number of piles that
people made in this experiment
was 7 and 1/2.
Correct answer's two, OK?
OK, now you might
say, well, maybe those
are shitty photographs, right?
OK, so here's the control.
Those are Dutch politicians.
They then did the same
experiment on Dutch people who
look at that photograph
and in about two seconds
say two, duh, OK?
So if you know there's nothing
wrong with those photographs,
it's just a matter of whether
you know those people or not.
OK, so the point of all of
this is that this crazy story
that, in fact, what a
lot of what we're doing--
I'm sort of simplifying
here, but a lot
of what we're doing
in face recognition,
a lot of the way we
deal with all this image
variability is not that we
have some very abstract, fancy,
high-level representation
of each individual face.
We just have lots of
experience with faces,
and we use that so
that if we have a novel
face that we don't have
all that experience with,
we're not so good at it.
I'm going to run out of time,
so I'll take one question
and go on.
AUDIENCE: How do they
control for-- you
know the issue you said about
if you don't have experience
with similar races.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
I'm sure whenever you do
face recognition experiments,
you make sure that if
your dominant subject
pool is Caucasian, you have
Caucasian faces or whatever.
Yeah.
Unless it's something
you don't understand--
I'm going to hang
around after class.
You can ask me questions
there, or if you have to go,
you can email me
because I really
want to get through
this next bit, OK?
OK, so there we are with that.
So what this suggests,
kind of, sort of,
is that whatever
we're doing, it's
something that
benefits enormously
from lots and lots of
experience with that individual.
Maybe it's not
literal memorization
of actual pixel-like snapshots,
but it's something more
like that than anybody
would have guessed
before this experiment, OK?
OK, all right, I'm going to
skip this awesome stuff here.
OK.
OK, so the benefits
of-- actually,
I'm going to come back and
do that slide next time, too.
And we're going to cut
straight to functional MRI.
I'm sorry about this, but I just
really want you guys to have
this background
in case you don't.
You probably do.
So functional MRI--
another cool method
in cognitive neuroscience, and
how would it be useful here?
OK, so first, what is it?
Functional MRI is the
same as regular MRI
that's in probably
tens of thousands
of hospitals around the world.
The big advances
in functional MRI
were when some physicists
in the early '90s
figured out how to take
those images really fast
and how to make images
that reflect not just
the density of tissue but
the activity of neurons
at each point in the brain, OK?
That was big stuff, OK?
Early 1990s.
And so the reason
it's a big deal
it is the best, highest
spatial resolution
method for making pictures
of human brain function
noninvasively.
That means without opening
up the head, all right?
So that's an important thing.
That's why there's lots
and lots of papers on it.
That's why we're going to
spend a lot of time on it.
The bare basics are that the
functional MRI signal that's
used is called the BOLD signal.
That stands for blood
oxygenation level
dependent signal, OK?
And what that means is this.
Basic signal is blood flow.
And so the way it works
is if a bunch of neurons
someplace in your brain
start firing a lot,
that's metabolically expensive
to make all those neurons fire,
and so you have
to send more blood
to that part of the brain.
So it's just like if you go for
a run, the muscles in your legs
need more blood delivered
to them to supply them
metabolically for that
increased activity,
and so the blood flow
increase to your leg muscles
will increase, OK?
Well, similarly, the
blood flow increases
to active parts of the brain.
Now, the weird part of it
is that for reasons nobody
completely understands,
the blood flow increase
more than compensates
for the oxygen use,
so the signal is
actually backwards.
Active parts of the brain
have less, not more,
deoxygenated hemoglobin compared
to oxygenated hemoglobin,
and the relevance of that is
that oxygenated hemoglobin
and deoxygenated
hemoglobin are magnetically
different in the way that
the MRI signal can see.
So the basic signal
you're looking at
is, how much oxygen
is there in the blood
in that part of the
brain, and hence,
how much blood flow went there?
And hence, how much
neural activity was there?
Did that sort of make sense?
I'm not going to test you
on which is paramagnetic
and which is diamagnetic.
I never remember.
I couldn't care less,
but you should know what
the basic signal is, right?
It's a magnetic
difference that results
from oxygenation
differences that
result from blood
flow differences that
result from neural activity.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when
there's more blood flow,
there's more oxygenated?
NANCY KANWISHER:
More oxygenated,
and because it overcompensates
for the metabolic use
of the neurons, the active parts
that you see with an MRI signal
have more oxygenated
hemoglobin, right?
OK, all right, so
that's the basic signal.
And because that's
the basic signal,
there's a bunch of things
we can tell already.
So first of all--
I'm just going to--
am I going to do this?
Yeah, I'm going
to skip over this.
It doesn't really matter.
Because it's all based
on blood flow, one,
it's extremely indirect--
neural activity, blood flow
change, overcompensation,
different magnetic
response, MRI image, right?
So you would think with
all those different steps
that you would get a really
weird, nonlinear, messy, crappy
signal out the other end.
And it is one of
the major challenges
of my personal atheism,
but actually, you
get a damn good signal
out the other end.
And it's pretty linear
with neural activity, which
seems like kind of
a freaking miracle,
given how indirect it is, OK?
But that has empowered
this whole huge field
to discover cool things about
the organization of the brain.
OK, nonetheless, there
are many caveats.
Because it's blood
flow, the signal
is limited in spatial
resolution down
to-- people fight about this,
but around a millimeter.
There are cowboys
in the field who
think that they can get
less than a millimeter.
Maybe.
I don't know.
It's debated.
And the temporal
resolution is terrible.
Blood flow changes
take a long time.
Think about it.
You start running.
How long does it
take before the blood
flow increases to your calves?
Well, if you're really fit,
it's probably fast, but still
going to take a few seconds.
It takes about six
seconds for those blood
flow changes in the brain
after neural activity.
And it happens over a
big sloppy chunk of time,
and so you don't have
much temporal resolution
with functional MRI.
Does that make sense?
OK.
OK, because it's this
very indirect signal,
that also means that when we
get a change in the MRI signal,
we don't exactly know
what's causing it.
Is it synaptic activity?
Is it actual neural firing?
Is it one cell
inhibiting another?
Is it a cell making protein?
I mean, it could be any
of these things, right?
So we don't know,
and that's a problem.
And another problem is
the number you get out
is just the intensity of the
detection of deoxyhemoglobin.
It doesn't translate directly
into an absolute amount
of neural activity.
The consequence of
that is all you can do
is compare two conditions.
You can never say, there
was this exact amount
of metabolic
activity right there.
You can only say it was
more in this condition
than that condition, OK?
All right, so those
are the major caveats.
Nonetheless, we can
discover some cool stuff.
OK, so let's suppose, to get
back to face recognition,
you wanted to know,
is face recognition
a different problem in the brain
from object recognition, right?
If it was, you might want
to write different code
to try to understand
it from the code you're
writing for object recognition.
It's something you'd
kind of want to know, OK?
So here's an experiment
I did-- god--
20 years ago.
Anyway, simplest
possible thing--
so it's the easiest way I can
explain to you the bare bones
of a simple MRI experiment.
You pop the subject
in the scanner.
You scan their head continuously
for about five minutes
while they look at
a bunch of faces.
For 20 seconds,
they stare at a dot.
They look at a bunch of objects.
They stare at a dot, OK?
It's a five-minute experiment.
You're scanning them
that whole time.
And then you ask, of each
three-dimensional pixel,
or voxel, in their
brain, whether the signal
was higher in that voxel
while the subject was
looking at faces than while they
were looking at objects, OK?
And when you do
that, you get a blob.
I've outlined it in green
here, but there's a little blob
there.
This is a slice through
the brain like this.
That blob is right in here
on the bottom of the brain.
And the statistics
are telling us
that the MRI signal is
higher during the face epochs
than the object epochs--
everybody with me here--
which implies very indirectly
that the neural activity
of that region was higher when
this person was looking at
faces than when they
were looking at objects.
OK, now whenever you
see a blob like that,
really, you want to see the data
that went into it, so here's
mine.
This is now the raw
average MRI signal
intensity in that bit
of brain over the five
minutes of the scan.
You can see the
signal's higher in that
region when the person
is looking at faces--
these bars here--
than when they're
looking at objects there.
Everyone get that?
That's what the
stats are telling us.
This is just the reality
check of the data
that produced those stats.
OK, so now, in fact,
you can see something
like that in pretty much
every normal person.
I could pop any of you in the
scanner, and in 10 minutes,
we'd find yours, OK?
Now, here's the key question.
Does this so far-- let's
suppose you find this in anyone.
You do all the stats you like.
It's as robust as you
could possibly want.
Do these data alone tell us
that that region is specifically
responsive to faces?
No.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: Because it could--
just like that certain
arrangement of features,
or it could be reacting to
the variable light intensities
that's reflecting off people's
skin-- coloration of the skin.
NANCY KANWISHER: Good.
Keep going.
What else?
Yes, you.
AUDIENCE: Different faces of
anything, like even animals.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, then
it might still be faces,
but it would be
different if it's
human faces versus any faces.
We kind of want to know, right?
The code would be different.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It might be
because of the face
is part of the bigger whole
and the object's a [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Uh-huh, the
face is a part of something,
absolutely, where the
object is the whole thing.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe the
orientation of the object
is so much simpler
than the human face is.
NANCY KANWISHER: Just
objects are simpler or maybe
just easier.
Maybe it's just
hard to distinguish
one face from another, and
so you need more blood flow.
Really, what that thing
is-- that's a generic object
recognition system, but
it has a harder time
distinguishing faces
from each other
because they're so similar.
So there's more activity.
Everybody get that?
OK, what else?
I'm going to go
two minutes over,
so if people have
to leave, that's OK.
I'll try not to go more
than two minutes over.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It could
just as easily
be responsible for seeing
maybe functional cues rather
than face recognition.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, yeah.
As I just said,
there's all this stuff
we get from a face, not just
who is it, but are they healthy?
What mood are they in?
Where are they looking?
All that stuff.
OK, so what you
guys just did-- this
is just basic common sense,
but it's also the essence
of scientific reasoning.
And we'll do a lot of
that in this class.
And the crux of the matter
is, here's some data.
Here's an inference.
And so your job is
to think, is there
any way that inference might
not follow from those data?
How else might we account
for those data, OK?
And you guys just did
that beautifully, OK?
So the essence of
good science is
whenever you see some data and
an inference, ask yourself,
how might that
inference be wrong?
How else might we
account for those data?
OK, so that's what
you guys just did.
I had previously made a list of
other things that might mean.
It could respond
to anything human.
You had said any kind of
face, but it could also
be just anything human,
may be a response
to hands, any body
part, anything
we pay more attention to,
anything that has curves in it,
or any of the suggestions
you guys made, OK?
So the crux of the matter in
how you do a good functional MRI
experiment or make a strong
claim about a part of the brain
based on functional
MRI is to take
all these alternative
accounts seriously.
And so as just one example, what
we did in our very first paper
is say, OK, there's lots
of alternative accounts.
Let's try to tackle
a bunch of them.
So we scan people looking at now
3/4 views of faces and hands,
and we made them press a button
whenever two consecutive hands
were the same-- that's
called a one-back task--
or whenever two consecutive
faces are the same.
By design, that task
is harder on the hands
than the faces,
so we were forcing
our subjects to pay more
attention to the hands
than the faces, OK?
And what we found is you get
the same blob, still responding
more to faces than hands.
And so the idea is
by showing that,
we've ruled out every
one of those things.
It's not just any
human body part.
It doesn't go to hands--
oh, sorry, anything human.
It's not just any body part.
It's not anything
we paid attention
to because we made them pay
more attention to the hands.
It's not anything with
curvy outline, OK?
And so that's just a
little tiny example
of how you can proceed
in a systematic way
to try to analyze what
is actually driving
this region of the brain.
You come up with a
hypothesis, and then you
think of alternatives
to the data.
And you come up with
more hypotheses,
and then you think
of ways to test them.
And we'll do a lot
of that in here.
OK, so that's what I
just said, and I'll just
say that there's lots
of data since then.
That region of the brain
actually extremely very much
prefers faces, and it's
present in everyone.
And next time, we will
talk about the fact
that that looks
like it's suggesting
that we have a different
system for face recognition
than object recognition.
But we haven't yet
nailed the case,
and you guys should all
think about what remains.
OK, thank you.
Sorry I was racing there.
I will hang out if you
guys have questions.